Three of the most common data formats are CSV,
XML, and JSON. I want to quickly discuss what one
record in the Lahman Baseball Database would look like in
each of these different formats. It just so happens that
the first row in this data set corresponds to a
pretty famous baseball player. Hank Aaron. Let's first discuss what
this data looks like in the format we originally downloaded
it in, CSV. In the CSV format we usually have
a series of rows. With each row corresponding to an
entry. There is a header row at the top of
our file. Where our comma separated values do not correspond
to an entry but instead tell us what each entry means
for the rest of the document. In the case of
this baseball document, our first row tells us that every
row will have some identifiers, the Lahman ID. The player
ID, the manager ID, et cetera. Then we'll see birth year,
birth month, birth day and then a bunch of other
statistics. If we go and look at the entry for
Hank Aaron. We see all of these values, 1 for
Lahman ID, aaronha01 for player ID, et cetera, separated by
commas. Note that if a particular player doesn't have a
value for one field, for example Hank Aaron does not
have a manager ID, we simply see two commas in
a row. In the case of an XML document, we end
up with something that pretty closely resembles HTML. We
can have a document element, which is opened. It can
then have a series of tables, which are also
opened, as we see here. The table has a number
of children, which correspond to the values that we
just discussed in the CSV 1 for Lahman ID, aaronha01
for player Id, etc. Note that when we're missing
a value in XML, things are treated a bit differently.
For example, since Hank Aaron was not a manager, we
just open the manager ID field and then put a
slash at the end. Finally, for a JSON document, we
have a number of JSON objects indicated by these curly
braces. A JSON object looks a lot like a Python
dictionary. We have keys. Which correspond to what we would
see in the header row in a CSV file followed
by values. Note that in the case of a missing value,
we simply open and close the quotation marks. Oftentimes,
the benefit of XML or JSON is that they support
nested structures in a way that CSV documents cannot.
I don't want to go into this in great detail,
but you can imagine that the value corresponding to
a particular JSON key, say braves, could itself be another
JSON object. Here's what that might look like. One final
note, is to remember that when we talk about different
formats that data can come in, it's not a
matter of the file extension being .CSV or being
.JSON. A file format really has to do with
how the data is organized inside of a file.
So we could easily have data that is formatted
in JSON or CSV, but that comes in a
file whose extension is .txt. Since the online MTA
subway data comes in CSV format, in the weather underground
API responds to requests with a JSON object. We'll discuss
how to load and process files in these two formats.
While we won't explicitly discuss loading and processing XML files,
it isn't that different than the material will cover with regards
to JSON and CSV. If you'd like to learn more
about dealing with XML data in particular. I recommend you take
the data wrangling class with Mongo DB taught here at
Udacity. For now, let's discuss how to work with CSV files.